hi welcome to this course on how to
structure your machine learning project
that is on machine learning strategy I
hope that through this course you learn
how to much more quickly and efficiently
get your machine learning systems
working so what is machine learning
strategy let's start with a motivating
example let's say you are working on
your cat crossfire and after working for
some time you've gotten your system to
have 90% accuracy but this isn't good
enough for your application you might
don't have a lot of ideas for how to
improve your system for example you
might think well let's collect more data
more training data or you might say
maybe your training set isn't diverse
enough yet you should collect images of
cats and more diverse poses or maybe a
more diverse set of negative examples
well maybe you want to train the album
longer with gradient descents or maybe
you want to try a different optimization
algorithm like the atom optimization
algorithm or maybe try a bigger network
or smaller network or maybe you want to
try on drop out or maybe l2
regularization or maybe you want to
change the network architecture such as
trying activation functions change
number of hidden units and so on and so
on
when trying to improve a deep learning
system you often have a lot of ideas but
things you could try and the problem is
that if you choose poorly it is entirely
possible the you end up spending six
months charging in some direction only
to realize after six months that that
didn't do any good
for example I've seen some teams spend
literally six months collecting more
data only to realize after six months
that it barely improves the performance
of their system so assuming you don't
have six months to wait on your problem
won't it be nice if you had quick and
effective ways to figure out which of
all of these ideas and maybe even other
ideas are worth pursuing
and which ones you can safely discard so
what I hope to do in this course is
teach you a number of strategies that is
ways of analyzing a machine learning
problem they'll help point you in the
direction of the most promising things
to try
what I'll doing this courses also share
of you a number of lessons I've learned
through building and shipping you know
large number of deep learning products
and I think these materials are actually
quite unique to this cause I don't see a
lot of these ideas being taught in
universities deep learning courses for
example it turns out also that machine
learning strategy is changing in the
area of deep learning because the things
you could do are now different with deep
learning algorithms than with previous
generation of machine learning
algorithms but I hope that these ideas
will help you become much more effective
at getting your deep learning system to
work